all right
welcome to our career master class the
habits of highly effective
engineers our guest today is ragavandra
gandhari
the head of software development at
tesco and our session today is
sponsored by freshers world
before we get started i'd just like to
go over the controls for webex
this far along in our work from home
people are probably all familiar
but if you want to put questions in
for raghavendra please put them in the q
a
so that we can handle those in the q
a portion of the event toward the end
and you feel free to put
comments in the chat rod vendor may
ask some questions that he'll ask you to
respond to in chat but please do
mark those to all panelists so that
we all see them here otherwise only i
see them and that doesn't help rugbender
we are going to be running several polls
yeah one at the beginning and one at the
end
let's start with this one
and it has as you can see two questions
here is the poll widget for those
of you streaming you can put your
answers in the chat
if you're on linkedin live or youtube
live
but for the rest of you you should have
the pull widget and
how much work experience do you have
first question
the second question is one that we've
been asking since the beginning of
lockdown and we're asking how you're
feeling today
and hopefully
doing well
we have
[ __ ] oh pardon me
i've been talking and i forgot to open
the poll
i'll just give this about 30 seconds
and five more seconds get your answers
in
it's an interesting distribution we've
got most people
either have more than five years
experience or they're still in school
um
and thankfully most of you are feeling
well today
um for the few of you who are not doing
so well
we hope that this presentation will give
you information that will
will help improve your outlook
and with that i'm going to introduce
drug mandra
he is as i said the head of software
development at tesco
over 18 years of experience in design
and development of software
um he's previously worked at infosys
he's done projects for apple computer
and e-commerce
and his passion is and best practices in
engineering
to raise the bar for himself his team
and
all the rest of us and so
welcome reg vendra and thank you for
joining us oops
i'm going to stop sharing this
so how are you doing today gordon
hey hi there sorry
there you go yeah okay uh good i i
understand uh some of your india and
some of your elsewheres so good morning
and
afternoon or evening uh whatever is your
current time zone
uh and i i really hope uh that you guys
are staying
safe uh i know certain parts of the
world
is really impacted heavily and i wish
all the best and i'm really really
hoping that you're uh
giving yourself your well-being and your
family the number one priority
that it deserves right now uh
coming to uh this particular session
right so uh i'll just sort of uh
reiterate uh
uh just just uh reintroduce myself um
so i've been working for about 18 years
and
about 15 of those working with
influences for
apple and uh the recent few years with
cisco as head of software
development and again uh what i'm going
to talk about today is a lot of it is
based off
of my personal experience having worked
with
some really really sharp engineers as
peers and now as managers or as
as a you know head of software
development and so on
and uh what i'm going to do is
uh essentially i have a list of things
right and
uh each one of those is basically
the reason i put that in uh in my list
of things to talk about today is
uh because at some point or the other in
my career i found that as
a very essential trait as a habit that
uh
that that eventually differentiates uh
uh you know you as an engineer
uh since you're talking about habits i
will not go too
technical right but some
and also some of those habits are i
think you know even if you choose not to
be an engineer if you choose to be a
professional i think some of those are
applicable uh nevertheless
right uh now the first thing uh you know
i i want to talk about is a primarily
around
around what you do to take action right
now
one of the things uh which i learned
i would say thankfully learned very
early on uh in my career is that
every crisis is actually an opportunity
right
and looking back uh some of the biggest
jumps
that i've had in my career right uh step
changes be it be it you know in the form
of
a a great amount of learning there in
terms of professional growth be
it in terms of uh professional
satisfaction about hey i achieved
something
it has been around uh you know when we
dealt when i dealt with uh some crisis
right
the crisis could be anything right it
could be uh something going on
in your project it could be about
a situation that you the company that
you're working on is facing
whatever it is right uh it is it is
extremely important and i cannot
emphasize how important it is to be
resilient
in those times when when times are
difficult and just do it do
do the right thing do it for doing the
right thing and not because
of a reward or anything like that reward
is a happy siding
and this is a habit right if you look at
most of the successful engineers and
again as i said
this one's probably not even about
engineers right
uh anyone who has been successful in
life has at some point
dealt with the crisis right and and
yeah i would say never let go a crisis
to waste right there's something in it
and of course you know
there are personal situations um where
you may not be able to invest yourself
in that crisis and that's okay that's
perfectly fine
all i would say is if you are able to
push yourself
to you know to deal with it and you know
i think it uh it will be extremely
rewarding
uh what happens you know during crisis
uh one of the important things is about
uh it's it's quite situational right
it's very much possible that
you would be low on confidence because
things have gone wrong
and you you may just feel hey i don't
know how to start it and that that's
what uh
a lot of us let go of a good crisis when
it's a
good crisis a good opportunity uh
because we are unable to find that
confidence right i think
that that is where uh it is very
important to be self-driven it just
takes that little push from yourself
uh to kind of you know really embrace
that of course uh there are
organizations
uh in some cases there are organizations
who are helpful they have
there's a very good culture that enables
and empowers it right
and in general of course i would strive
to build such a culture
in in the organization that i'm leading
but
uh it's it's again it's hard right
because there's so many factors at play
so it's very important that you find
confidence and you're
you are self-realized the next thing uh
a
habit that um uh that
differentiates uh every uh
differentiates really really effective
engineers
is bias to action right uh you could
probably uh you know go back and relate
to a lot of work that
you you have been doing and just think
about your peers and think about
the stakeholders you work with right one
thing that is extremely
highly appreciated is bias to action
right uh because a lot of times we get
into
i think there's a there's a term for it
i think we call it analysis paralysis as
when you talk about it you talk about
your analyze
talk yeah you analyze the talk and
eventually nothing gets done
right and if you think that's happening
around you
i guess you know just show bias to
action just get started
it makes a huge difference uh i i sort
of remember i
i think you guys are familiar with
you're familiar with this dilbert comic
right
i remember reading one a while ago it
said it said like you know
it took us five days to figure out that
we were two days ahead
now we are three days behind right and
that's what happens a lot of times in
terms of
you you're really kind of overthinking
and sort of acting right
so it's extremely important to act and
again you know
you can apply that in your particular
context right and the engineer that i
work with i mean there is
there is kind of unparalleled uh i i
would say
the the top engineer that i have worked
with and i am working with have
unparalleled bias to action
uh a thing that is very close to bias to
action and in fact i think it also
connects with the crisis thing that i
said
earlier is about just show up right
uh there are uh what i mean by show up
is
there is a tendency sometimes um think
about let's say uh
since some of you are already working in
your organization for more than five
years
um think about let's say a production
incident an issue uh
in in the context of a software right
where uh something is going wrong nobody
knows what's going on
right a lot of times the tendency is to
like oops okay let me just
get get okay it's not my problem
let me not worry about it right and and
that's probably okay but
you know uh if you're able to i would
highly highly encourage you to just show
up
just jump in and see what's going on see
how you could help
and again um it kind of creates a
a really uh this habit essentially right
it it teaches you how it teaches
a number of things right one about uh
really
uh figuring out like you know uh how you
could help in various situations
it kind of makes you a reliable uh
person in in the context right you know
that uh if there is a problem this
person shows up
right and lends a helping hand and that
is extremely
important right so again as i said if
you are able to right of course
what the reason i'm saying if you're
able to especially that becomes a lot
relevant in the current context
there may be personal situations uh
because of which
you may not be able to and that's okay
right so i would not want to talk about
that exception here right
but in general whenever you can't you
whenever you can you show up
um and again it's it's it's not
something it's not a short-term benefit
right it's it's not that okay i show up
here whether my boss is noticing me or
not
whether my peers are seeing me as you
know being effective or not
uh if you if you go for that right uh
it's it's a very short-lived
um uh uh it's it's a very short-lived
thing right
it's really about doing the right thing
showing up when there is a need right
again all these things that i'm talking
about are in in the in the lines
of um uh
acting and taking initiatives right
which which is what uh which is the next
thing right
take initiatives don't wait and stop
asking for permission right
uh of course there are certain times uh
certain organizations have
bureaucratic requirements and you
probably need uh to wait for something
right
and that's okay it happens from time to
time
but most often right it's really about
hey take initiative and
i will guarantee that majority of the
times when you take initiative
right it gets appreciated and more
importantly uh
uh you are able to shape it right you
you're also it there's a good chance
that if you are taking an initiative on
something
uh there's a good chance that you get to
shape the solution and shape shape it up
end to end right uh if not that's still
okay right
taking an initiative itself is a habit
that that that gradually will start
differentiating you as an excellent
engineer because
it's about grabbing opportunity and it's
also about being able to add value in
whatever context
that is right now in this and that's why
it's important sometimes to stop
asking for permission right now of
course you don't break law or you don't
kind of do something really really crazy
right and that's that's obviously
unacceptable right
but for a simple thing right again
the industry is moving towards uh you
know we're talking about
agile uh workspaces and so on and there
are a number of
things uh what it means and one of the
critical thing it really means
is uh we would love to have engineers
who are self-driven and and we'd love to
have a team
uh that is self-organizing right this
cannot happen
if uh as an engineer you're waiting for
things to be told
to you right and and i think that's kind
of an old-school
thought where you know you you are you
you're there and you're you're being
told
what to do and then you do it and then
you wait for something else
to be told something else right and that
just does not scale right and that will
also limit your potential
and and i'm not saying this in a light
way right it limits your potential in a
really really big way
right so and hence it's very important
that you
talk about how you you or what kind of
initiative that you could take
now and and that's where you know in in
in a really uh
in a really good legion environment
right so
in a typical environment what happens is
work is
uh rather not in a typical environment
in a traditionally what
used to happen was a manager assigns
work and you know the work is completed
and then you know ask for
status right and and i think that's
that's a complete reverse way of doing
it right an ideal thing is where the
work is pulled that the engineers say
hey i can do this and you do it
and you push the status you update the
status you keep you know keep those
keep your stakeholders informed in the
head is what's going on right
and and um
this habit of engineers right is really
one of the essential ingredients to
make a highly effective team as well
because
as a manager or as a speaker i can trust
you to do the right thing for your team
and and if i can have
everyone in the team doing that right uh
it's it's unquestionably one of the best
uh
dynamics to be in right now
on this notion right uh there is one um
we often hear that at workplace right
and we often hear this thing about hey
there's politics going on
there's favoritism going on um
occasionally
uh it's true and in certain companies
which
where the culture is not necessarily
evolved it's true and at the end of the
day
there are humans and it's a human
tendency but that probably constitutes a
very very small percentage if you look
at it
you know in a broader context right
that's a very small percentage of things
in majority of the cases right if there
is favoritism or if
let's say if you're seeing that a given
engineer is getting all the cool pieces
of work
right it's very likely that the engineer
has built that
credibility right and that's why i would
say you know
good work always leads to good work
right as you know if you if you
if you feel that you are you're stuck in
doing some mediocre work or
a work that you are not interested in
right the best way to break out of that
cycle is do some good work take
initiative do some good work
and that attracts more good work and
that's how you build right
you you volunteer for things you show
initiative
and more importantly you finish what you
started right and i have had i've seen
uh
engineers and uh to be uh to be very
honest i have also
uh you know in in the in the enthusiasm
of it right i picked up something i
volunteered i showed initiative but then
i did not finish what i started right
and obviously if that happens you are
not you're not building any credibility
right so
it's very important you you show
initiative
you you finish what you start you build
your credibility and the cycle
repeats right uh this is uh again this
is a habit of acting right
you you're not it's more about taking an
initiative you act on it
and you build credibility and and that's
how you know
over a period of time you know the more
good work you do the more
opens up more opportunities right it's
like a um
it's like a self-fulfilling or
self-feeding
loop right and the way you start it is
by showing initiative right
now these are all all the things that i
said
was about acting right and now i want to
talk a little bit about
mindsets right now one of the thing uh
which again inhibits us
right is about a fear of being wrong
right now again there is a bit of a
company or a workplace culture uh that
could
that plays a role here but what i'm
talking about is a culture that is
really progressive right or
or i would say an ideal right the
culture of the place where i would prime
uh for example my team to be and i can i
can
i can guarantee you that a lot of
[Music]
a lot of folks are trying to build
engineering organizations around it is
where
people are not afraid to be wrong right
and people are not
sorry people and people are not afraid
to admit that they're wrong right so
that's
it's a the point being that you know if
as a culture if you remove the blame out
of the equation
it really empowers the engineers but
then even outside of that as a habit
right
uh i think a lot we are inhibited a lot
by
by by being afraid of being wrong right
it's okay
of course it's a different thing if you
keep making the same mistakes again and
again and again right
that obviously means that you're not
learning and that's not a desirable
behavior right
it's about not being afraid of being
wrong and
uh an equally uh
a similar thing there is about embracing
failures right and
i know if there is time later in the i
cannot go into the details like there is
time i can talk about
uh you know there are a lot of failures
that i have embraced right and i can
talk about some of those things and what
i've learned and you know how
how it kind of helped me across an
engineer but also how i turned this
around
in some cases right so it's important to
be that and it's also important to be
vocally self-critical right about
see it's if uh if there's a
one of the one of the critical things
right as as professionals we need is
about
being self-aware right which means
uh you are aware of your strengths
you're aware of your weakness if you're
not in the same ballpark right
it's very difficult because no one can
help you like let's say if you are
if you are doing something uh you know
let's see if if you're an entry level in
something and you know you you you're
talking about
doing something it's totally
unassociated and you know and you're
talking about
something that is completely unrelated
the feedback
or whatever the conversation they are
not even on the same uh uh same
wavelength right so it's very important
to be self-aware so that you can have
those conversations
and you hold yourself accountable right
of course you also need to hold others
accountable uh
again and not in the interest of not not
about blaming them it's about
putting others accountable for what they
said they do they will do but they have
not done and it's a right it's a good
thing it's a good culture where
everyone can we can hold each other
accountable it starts with you right
so it starts with you holding yourself
accountable if you said you want to do
something you could not do it
before somebody else holds you
accountable you hold yourself
accountable you you say you know
you'll be vocally self-critical and say
hey this is what i could have done i
missed it i'll take care of it next
again this this just talks about your
process right now by doing this you are
sort of embracing
uh the embracing your weakness but more
importantly you're recognizing what is
it that you could do better
and you're doing it and as a
as you go through this process right and
i think one of the things mistakes we do
sometimes when we try to benchmark
ourselves with with everyone else right
uh there is this conversation but hey
he's getting so much hype he's getting
he's doing this
and and it's okay but it's not gonna
help you much right
what is very important is that you
benchmark yourself against yourself and
you know it seems like a whatsapp
forward or something where
you know a similar motivational thing
has come but this i'm saying this from
from uh from a very
practical you know experience one of the
common conversations which i have with
my team is about hey uh
what have you learned in the last few
months right in general the way i would
look at it
right let's say you did something about
a year ago right
and you did well it was a it was pretty
a job done pretty well
and now i ask hey um
what do you think like you know if
you're doing that now would you have
done anything better
and if the answer is yes then i can i
know that the person is growing
if the answer is no then it's it's it's
a bit bothersome for me because
what it means is that over a period of a
year you haven't really you know
learned uh you haven't figured out how
to go to the next level from there right
so it's very important a benchmark
yourself right like hey
uh whatever i'm doing even in fact pick
the best thing that you did
six months ago three months ago one year
ago and see if you're doing
it now would you do something better
right and
and you are growing as long as as the
answer is yes to that question it could
be anything that could be something very
small
something big but it needs to be yes and
that kind of shows that
shows the shows that you're improving as
an engineer right
now speaking of mindset right uh
one other thing one of the uh this is
one a very important
tool which uh i i don't think everybody
really uses it very effectively and it's
a tool about
uh seeking and receiving feedback right
now receiving feedback does not
necessarily mean
that you know whatever feedback you get
you have to blindly accept it right
there is there's
there's a difference between receiving
feedback and accepting feedback
as in uh agreeing to the feedback right
now
uh what is very important that you're
always open about receiving the feedback
you seek out the feedback and you ask
you you understand what the other person
is meant to tell
and then it's up to you you introspect
on it in some cases
maybe there is something in some case
maybe there isn't but a mistake you
could
it would be a complete mistake if you if
you
get a feedback but just because you
don't agree with it you don't even pay
an attention right you
you try to get very defensive about it
right and being defensive is one of the
worst things that you could do it's a
habit that
that's going to again inhibit your
growth right so what i would say
is seek and receive feedback and if
you're in in a situation in an
organization or somewhere where
you're not getting the right feedback i
think i think that that's kind of a
signal that that's
that that is bothersome right um if
and usually what i i advise is you know
again you know if you're not getting in
fact even if you are getting good
feedback from your manager
there's no reason you cannot reach out
to other mentors within the organization
outside the organization does not matter
right
you talk about you receive feedback you
you you introspect it and you
act on it right you act on it you you
finally
ultimately you make your own decision
right it's uh the message if you are
just blindly accepting everything
you know is that is being given to you
as a feedback that is also a big problem
right so about having the growth
mindset being open to receiving feedback
and
not getting defensive because if you get
defensive the next time you will not get
a good feedback
you know a lot of us lose out on good
feedback just because they're getting
defensive
while it is being received you're not
you are you're being disrespectful to
the person who's giving the feedback if
you're being defensive right so please
do not be defensive
seek and receive as much you know
receive feedback from the right people
and you know um develop empathy and
emotional
intelligence right now what happens this
is one of the one of the
um it's it's a very tricky thing right
uh because again uh it's
it may be a little more uh as engineers
i guess you know it's not
i'm not saying that we are not
empathetic we are but i think there is a
there is a different level of again
there is a lot of cultural there is a
lot of uh
your own background everything comes
into play but empathy is a very strong
um very strong thing right but if for
example if you cannot empathize with
uh with your stakeholders right it will
it will become almost impossible for you
to manage their expectations right
a lot of times i hear engineers
complaining of oh that product manager
you know he's just screaming or you know
the client is screaming and so on right
uh i mean it's important because okay
what's going on there right
it's very important to understand their
point of view if you cannot do it right
you will always be okay i'm doing the
right thing
and and that's it right you you're just
putting yourself in a box right
uh it's important to have the empathy
have this
those conversations understand what
people are going you know where they're
coming from and then of course work
towards the solution right
you understand okay this is what's going
on and you know
why don't we do this right you you kind
of collaborate your collaboration
increases significantly right so and
again it's something that could be
developed right i mean i know there is
there's a lot of natural uh
uh a lot of people are born with it
naturally but it's also something that
could be developed
um one of the ways i think you know you
could you could really improve yourself
right is connect and surround yourself
with folks who are better than you
right and don't don't try to be the
smart
don't be the smartest person in the room
at all times
right which means they know of course
you can learn from everybody i'm not
denying that right
but if you always try to the smartest
person in the room that means you're
probably not learning right you you're
the
you're the one who's who is teaching
others
right it's important to be surrounded
with people who are smart right because
smarter than
for smarter than you at least in some
aspects so that you could have these
conversations
you could have those debates you could
have those points of view right
if you do not have one in your team seek
out right i mean you have
you have your professional network you
can think of about maybe some of your
old friends who are you know who have
been really really good
uh with whom you think are smarter than
you and pick their brain right
uh and english just uh i i'm pretty sure
a lot of people wouldn't mind
you know if you want to just just speak
their brain and
just uh get their input on things right
i'm sure a lot of people would not mind
it is important to get that point of
view right again all these are
little data points they'll be collecting
right saying that hey can i do this
candidate
what up what what happens and and then
suddenly oh yeah something clicks okay
these are the things a pattern that i'm
observing is this is one area where i
don't do well and if i do this
well i could really really uh become a
much more effective engineer and so on
right
so it's so it's very important um you
try and you know
embrace yourself uh with the folks who
are better than you right
uh while i'm talking about this let me
also talk about a few
don'ts right uh a few things which
really inhibit
uh you you know uh in in ways that you
cannot even uh
imagine right uh there are these things
for uh philosophical
razors right uh again um without
sounding daunting right these are just
real
thumb rules uh uh which which talks
about what makes
uh to kind of really make sense and
rational
[Music]
think rationally around things that are
going wrong right well there's one
particular thing called hand lungs razor
what it says is never attribute to
malice
that which can be adequately explained
by stupidity right
now this talks about there is this
mindset a lot of times where you think
if something wrong has happened you
think that somebody is plotting against
you or somebody is
conspiring against you now it's probably
true in some of the soap operas
uh but in real life the the chance
of someone targeting you and plotting
against you and bringing your downfall
is very very small
it's obviously it's not impossible
people do find themselves in situations
where this can happen
but the more common one the higher
chance is that
you know they're just being either
they're just being stupid or
they're being ignorant or it's just it
just you know
happened now here here is something
right
i think sometimes what happens is uh
especially when you are low on
confidence
on something right an act of it it tends
to impact you more
right it tends to impact you like you
know let's say you are let's say you had
a
bad present let's say you made a bad
presentation or you wrote a bad
piece of code and something like that
that happened and
following that the next day let's say uh
you know you try you think your manager
and
or you know someone and they did not
respond right now it's
uh this could happen on any regular day
that you think someone and they don't
respond it's very much
possible right but if these happen in
this sequence you might start
associating that you might start saying
okay because uh okay my managers or
whoever it is upset with me and they
don't want to talk to me and then you
start you know if you start kind of you
know
and then you think okay this is the
person because of who who had a
malicious intent and you know
that's why this happened uh give them
the benefit of the doubt right
more often than not it's just simple uh
you know a simple uh stupidity that that
would explain it
if it happens again and again and if it
is really malicious
you wouldn't know but but that have the
open mindset right
and the reason i'm saying this is again
uh this prevents us
you know this creates a lot of friction
i've seen this creating friction between
engineers i've seen i've had one-on-ones
with engineers where they talk about
okay i think this person
is does not like me and you know i see
that this person always tries to bring
me down
and so on and and again what i've seen
is
on digging further and most of the times
it's
just uh this razor not being you know
considered
there are some cases where yes it has
happened where they were genuinely being
you know
had malicious intent and like i said
it's a small it's it's an exception it's
not the norm
so don't let that deter you right
because you will lose opportunities
because if you start
if you start going into that eventually
you'll get very paranoid
and you get into victim frame rate
you're always like you always get into
this thing about
uh complaining about hey you know this
person always criticizes my code
uh this person always makes you know
never gives me good work
this person you know my manager always
you know picks on me and all these
things right
you gradually get into this victim frame
and once you're there right
it's it's it's really really really bad
place to be in right
now so please you know try and not get
to that time there is your
basic human psychology at play here and
you know beyond a limit maybe you cannot
fight it right
but then just keep all i would say is
there's this in mind right
uh where the handles razor in mind try
and not be in victim frame of mind right
and you know as i said uh if you're
serious in
situations unique i trust you will be
able to make the best judgment call
based on your surroundings
but please keep this in mind that it is
a thing it is not something that i'm
making up you can look it up on
wikipedia it's been around for a long
long time
yeah the second thing is just the
opposite of it right
uh please please do not be cynical do
not be vindictive
you do not be manipulative or revengeful
it's
absolutely not worth it uh you you're
sucking the energy out of
yourself but you're also sucking the
energy out of the people around you
right
if you have been wronged uh i mean again
i have seen this happen right let's say
this one engineer or one person had a
bad experience
you try you you do you just go ahead and
spread toxicity around it you
be vindictive and you start you know
blaming someone for
no real reason right it doesn't serve
any purpose right eventually you will be
seen as someone who cannot be trusted
right someone who if you're manipulative
uh you know
just like in life right you will you
will have that reputation
uh i would say in general it's not worth
it
right some people do get away with it
but in the long run it's absolutely not
worth
it and hence i would say you know try
and stay away from
negativity and negative people like this
right and and
please do introspect if you are one of
those guys right so
for unknown reason if you are give a
real hard thought
on whether it's worth it what will where
it will take you over a period of time
right
and believe me uh if you are cynical
vindictive manipulative or eventful
right
uh it's it's just a matter of time you
will not be able to collaborate very
well
you will other engineers around your
peers around you will
not have a good opinion about you and
you will you'll get boxed
right it's just a matter of time so
please you know watch out for that
you may switch your company you may
switch the context and it's just a
matter of time again where you will fall
into that right so
i would highly encourage you to not get
into that habit
the other thing other habit which which
again you know this is one thing where i
uh i i would i would look at this
probably as one of the biggest
uh you know something that could really
provide a step change a lot right
is around communication right uh i've
seen
a lot of times right where engineers are
good at just putting the head down and
working working working getting things
done
uh and they they do an extremely poor
job of communicating right they are not
communicating the status they are not
communicating what's going on
and then uh you end up complaining
saying that you know i did all these
things my manager does not
understand this my manager does not
appreciate it right
and uh but you're not communicating
right
there are no mind readers here right and
especially if you have if you're in a
very complex
work environment right uh there's no way
anyone can humanly keep track of what's
going on so communication is very
important now
please do not go to the extreme and
start you know start beating your
drums for every single thing that you
did right now that's going to productive
i'm not talking about that
i'm just talking about very very basic
communication that is
applicable in your context now
communication is not just about
work right it's also about
you know uh uh what do you have in mind
right let's say there is
if you have an aspiration right
um and you see your manager is not you
know
um you might struck me oh i want to do
this i want to work on this technology
but you know i'm not getting opportunity
ask yourself have you ever talked about
this with your manager have you ever
communicated have you ever spoke
spoke about this right uh a lot of times
you might feel like hey it's but it's
obvious
uh believe me it's not right so it's
important
please do communicate uh nobody can read
your mind right
and then i'm telling this from my own
experience i remember in this case i was
the engineer and i wanted certain things
to happen and i told my and
i thought it was obvious because of my
behavior and because of some of those
things
and when i told my manager hey this is
something that i wanted to do and i saw
a look of genuine surprise like oh okay
but i thought you were happy with this
i never knew that you wanted to do this
right and and that's the moment i
realized yeah i never
talked to you about it right so and you
know in fact all these while i was
actually in my head i was cultivating
i'm not getting this off i started
gradually you know developing a bit of
i was a hatred but a bit of a grudge on
hey why is this not happening why is you
know this manager not doing this for me
and so on
and eventually it turned out to be my
fault i was not communicating
right so think uh think about that it's
very important to communicate
uh you know what you need uh over
communication under communication you
know
uh be the judge in your context but
please do speak up
right and the other thing about coming i
i mentioned earlier about
um receiving feedback right i would also
say you know
feel free to give feedback and don't
impose anything don't don't go and say
you know hey
i know there are some uh uh who are like
sorry pardon my language uh hey i i'm
saying this you've got to do this you've
got to
just get into a you know a mode where
you're trying to convince the other
person right
uh that could be counterproductive
unless this you know unless you have an
equation with that person as you know
childhood friends or something like that
right but if you see something that is
not going right
right it's very important to give
feedback to the person who is
you know uh who's doing this now this is
something that i actually
i would say uh something that i wish i
had learned much earlier in my career
right where i found something that did
not look good but then i thought
yeah what's in it you know why do i care
and you know and or
maybe this person will not appreciate
the feedback and step back right
but what i learned is about the value of
giving feedback
you know of course you know you don't
want to give unsolicited feedback or you
don't want is the person whom you're
giving feedback is completely close to
it
maybe you kind of step back but i think
you owe it to the other person as a
professional to start giving that
feedback whatever you observe right it's
i think it's it's important
i think in fact the whole giving
feedback extends right
for those who have worked in the
industry we talk about design reviews we
talk about
pull request reviews everything right
it's really about giving feedback on
something that uh you know that you've
done these are all in the very formal
context
and i think it works out there but i'm
talking about something more you know
something about
uh uh something very more very basic
right
for example let's say you written an
email and email was not
[Music]
where you're trying to explain something
and it is not clear enough
right there's no reason why you could
not go to the person and say hey by the
way i read this email that you sent
i thought i found it a little confusing
maybe if you do this i think it'd be
better right
give this feedback and again sometimes
some people won't appreciate that
feedback so be it but others who would
benefit from it would really benefit
from it and you're also again
excuse me
with all these what you're really doing
is you're building your own credibility
right and and as you grow in your career
i think that becomes very important
right ability to give feedback um
your thoughts are value because you're
doing this right people find
the value in this right so so please you
know
try and cultivate that habit now so far
i've been talking a lot about
technical sorry uh non-technical
behavior uh
i'll just go with a few things uh about
technical not not
in terms of very deep but just in terms
of engineering practices and things like
that right
now again there are something some
habits here which i think
i would encourage highly in my team some
of these
may need to be adapted in your context
right one thing
very which is universal though is
whatever you're working on whichever
project you're working on whichever
problem statement you're working on
uh be very sure to ask yourself this
question right
do you know what is the problem you're
solving and why you're solving the
problem right
because again you know if you do not
know the answer to that then you're
probably wasting your time
right because you you just kind of you
know you're probably working maybe for
the
salary or the end of the month which is
not a waste but you know that's about it
you're not you don't really care about
what you're building right so please you
know think about it like what's the
problem you're trying to solve is this
the best way to solve it right
and why are you solving it who's going
to benefit from it right a lot of times
we fail to ask those questions and we
just look
at this okay this is the this is the
requirement or this is the story
depending on what is whatever is your
practice when you go ahead and implement
it right
again it will limit it will limit your
ability to provide good solutions right
because
uh maybe if you understood the problem
better there may be much more novel and
creative ways of doing it and you are
depriving yourself of that opportunity
by not asking right questions
asking this question will lead to you
building the right thing
and also building the thing right right
so
so please always always you know try and
understand what you're building
the second thing is around again you
know this is about again this is my
personal
favorite style of working is find the
smallest increment that you could do
i trade and you know learn from it and
repeat and it
has short cycles of iterations right now
this is a habit that you know
again you know i i try and have it in my
team
and over a period of time i've seen this
work in so many different places right
the beauty of this is no matter how big
the problem is how big the
project is or whatever it is right this
methodology this framework lets you move
forward right it lets you move forward
in a very very logical way
and also lets you uh make progress and
also also test on that progress and so
on
right so so yes and try and get
there are some situations that this does
not apply but as long as it can be
applied please
try and do that right one of my favorite
uh
methodologies of again there are various
schools of thought one of the things
that i
really really am after you know given
any opportunity i would i would advocate
for it i'm advocating that for my team
very very strongly
is the notion of continuous delivery and
continuous deployment uh
so for those who are not familiar this
is a methodology where
uh so right now what happens is there's
a lot there is a complete
development life cycle where you build
something then then it's tested and
it goes through cycles and eventually
there is a release cycle and then it's
pushed into production there are
different teams doing different things
uh some organizations have to be set up
that way because there are constraints
but
a lot of organize a lot of new age
organizations or not right and
there there is this concept of countries
delivery where the concept is that
you build something small and if it and
then you have
if everything looks good it gets
deployed into production
within maybe a few minutes right now
this looks very powerful but again as uh
you know
as the saying goes the great power comes
between so the great responsibility
comes
sorry responsibility right
now this for this to work it's extremely
extremely important that you have
you have a very very solid uh pipeline
right the devops element of it right
where
uh you know you have tests in place you
have a robust test pipeline
you also have uh you know you're
following test driven development
exclusively right because if any of
those things are not
aligned uh your continuous deployment
would
fail and it will fail dramatically right
but then
once you're able to invest your time and
thought on setting this
up right it it it is very empowering
right because there's a habit where what
you're doing is if you're thinking
of the problem not in you know as a as a
huge thing you're breaking it down the
smallest thing that can actually be
delivered right
and in my experience what happens is
this allows you to move uh you know the
initial thing may be smaller but
you do you learn from it and you get
inputs and you go over a period of time
you start moving faster and faster and
faster right
so again uh as i said this is a bit
technical in the in the context that uh
this is about
um uh this probably is uh applicable
uh if your organization supports it but
then uh
if you are thinking about ways to
develop i would highly recommend you
look up the country the concept of
continuous delivery continuous uh
deployment and you know the test driven
development these uh this kind of really
go
hand in hand very well now the meta
point around this
is you know uh try and go for right
practices
right now practices are different from
processes sometimes processes can be
very bureaucratic and it can actually
slow you down right
you know i need to do this i need to get
this approval and if you have if you set
up a process like that as an
organization
uh you are going to frustrate the
engineers right
so so but it's very important have the
right practices the one i said about
has driven development is practice right
uh a practice of let's say
making sure that if there is any
exception uh
in you know production for you go ahead
and fix it right away right as soon as
possible that is a practice
so it's important to give a good thought
about these practices
and as engineers right a lot of times
what we do is okay uh
you there's a misconception that all the
practices are owned
by the managers and i'm just gonna
follow what they say right
please don't right this comes back to my
earlier point about in a show initiative
right if something is not working for
you
right and a lot of organizations are
going agile and agile is all about
adapting you know
looking what's not working and fixing it
right you have a stake in it and if in
fact i would even go to the extent of
saying that you're seeing something
wrong
and you are not acting on it you're
you're probably doing like
you're actually doing something uh wrong
you should not be
you know you you should own it please
own it right
and see what you could what you could
give see what you could do to improve
those practices
right and this is how you raise the bar
for yourself and for the team
right it's all about observing the
practices
participating in it and raising the bar
now
this again you know i've seen uh the
smartest engineers that i've worked with
or the engineers that i really
are right uh they have this this is a
habit that just
they are always you know they had this
habit of really coming up with normal
ways of doing things
and just raising the bar for themselves
and for the team right so if nobody's
doing it in your team
you could be that person right so please
i think about it
another thing as uh you know uh again a
lot
it is an engineering thing is around a
lot of times we
try and complicate things right to
simplify you know uh
go back to basics in fact uh uh one of
the
oh i i i have a four year old and you
know i was just you know he
watches all these little uh orion uh you
know things on television and so on and
there is this
little rhyme or i think it's called
three pigs or something like that where
one pig is building a house made of
straws and the other pig is
building a house made of you know sticks
or something like that and then there is
a house made of
uh brick and mortar and what it shows is
there's a wolf that comes it blows on it
and the first
house fly away and the one that is built
strongly written right
now it's it's it's just a little you
know fun uh rhyme for the kids
but uh it's quite amazing when you're
seeing that it's applicable to
all context right a lot of times we we
we compromise the quality of the
software that we built because we want
to build something
quick and it's okay to build something
quick because maybe
it's
i can fix it i'll come back and make it
stronger and if you do not do it this is
exactly what's going to happen when
there's a
when there's a credit when there is you
know something uh
like a wayne equal it happens it just
blows away your
work right so uh having a
house made of straw as an iteration is
perfect in the interest of rapidly
moving that is perfect
but if you stop there then you know
you're not setting yourself up for
success and
again you know uh this is about you know
having the the uh being passionate about
improving the quality of whatever you're
owning right
so uh so yeah so the so again uh another
back
back to basics right there is this uh
thing uh in software
uh engineering i think we call it the
boy scout principle right essentially
it's just about okay
leave the code in a place better than
what how we found it
right ask yourself how many of you
actually follow it's very very small
number
right and again this is a small things
that you could do to raise the bar
raise the quality of your team now
the other thing around that is you know
um there's
there's again you know sometimes what
you do is you try and put something in
your code
you think hey just something for short
just for this release and you forget it
right and then somebody else sees and
makes think okay hey this is an accepted
practice and you start building more and
more and more
uh things around that the equivalent
that we'll see in our daily lives is
imagine if you was you might be able to
relate to it if you imagine if you have
a street which is clean
someone throws a piece of garbage on
that on day one
and you know and you it's left there day
two it's left there
in three or four days more people start
throwing garbage there and
over a period of time that becomes the
garbage bin right
so it's really about uh you know uh
not allowing those you know things to
get conducted then
now i think we're sort of running out of
time so i'll try and wind it up
uh as an engineer one of the best things
that you could do is uh
seek the joy of creation right i think
as as
uh you know i i think that this quote
about follow your bliss right if you
really enjoy
uh you know being an engineer uh seek
the joy of creation and in all the
things that i said
uh you know is eventually guiding you
towards that right
so um yeah so i think i had a couple of
other things but
uh i guess i'm running out of time uh so
i'll probably uh try and
wind it up here and i think we can go
move towards the questions
right we can go into the q a now and um
but
that's a been a fantastic presentation
uh rugben
you get a lot of comments from the
attendees about how much they've
been enjoying it and how useful it's
been
there's a lot of questions here far more
than we can get to
but i want to take a few of them we have
ashes who's a
fresher graduated uh in the it field in
2014 he wants to
he's switching from the business field
to the i.t field and he
is considering um moving into ai
engineering um is that going to be a
difficult transition for him and how can
you make it uh
easier uh sorry transition from what to
what
from the business i.t uh into
um aai engineering sure yeah um i think
uh
is it difficult transition it's a bit of
a relative question right
uh i have folks done it yes people have
right and in fact
maybe one of the one of the things is
about it all comes down to your learning
ability right
it's very much possible right but i
would say if you're doing it for you
know just do it for the right reasons
right are you passionate about it is it
something that you think you you are
interested in does it drive you right
and i think uh and which and are you
showing this i think some of the
behaviors some of the habits that i
spoke about earlier
uh are you will you be able to you know
embrace that and if the answer is yes i
think you know uh it's it's a transition
that you should go for
and if you think uh some of the you know
if you're not
up for it uh again you know please uh
give it a thumbs up
okay um arnava
asks how do you provide feedback to a
peer
at the same level without being labeled
a fault finder
yeah um he he asked
in the context of you know a pr project
that's under a tight deadline you really
have to give this feedback to somebody
that to keep everything
going right and you know what how do you
how do you handle it
no absolutely i think it's it's a very
tricky question i fully appreciate and
understand that right
i think a lot of it uh one of the things
i think your tool here is really empathy
right and you have to build a
relationship with the person if you look
out cold and start giving feedback right
it
may or may not be received very well
right so a lot of it is about how you
build relationship with your peers
and in fact sometimes a good thumb rule
is you actually ask the permission to
give them feedback more like
hey by the way i had some observations i
wanted to share it with you for your
consideration are you okay with this and
if they say no i think you know you
cannot give feedback and if they are
open for it
uh it's it's the beginning of a
relationship and uh
uh yeah you also have to choose the
right words then you're giving the
feedback right if you say you are not
doing this well and you know
you do not when you're giving feedback
right you
cannot be attacking the person you are
actually giving the feedback on what's
going on
you take the personal out of it so
giving feedback
again it's a delicate uh you know it's
something that you kind of phone over a
period of time
uh but i would what i would say is you
start with
you know asking them hey i have some
feedback would you mind if i share it
with you and that's that's how you begin
the relationship
and i have done this in the past and my
peers have done it with me as well so
i i think that would work uh if the
other person who's receiving feedback is
having a good open mind about it
um we have a couple of questions that
are related about
uh you know what if you're talking with
your supervisor what if you're in the
session where you're receiving feedback
from your superior
and they accuse you of something that
you didn't do
yeah or in general if there's if there's
something that's unfair
or they misunderstood how do you respond
to that without
seeming defensive yeah uh this is uh
an absolutely uh i think it happens
right even even in mature organizations
uh it happens even in organizations that
have a very progressive work culture
tends to happen right because at the end
of the day it's a human behavior right
and i guess again i think i i spoke
in between about empathy and about kind
of you know putting yourself in the
other person's shoes
and what that really means again is in
how what kind of equation you can have
with the person right
now uh in the past right to be honest i
struggled with this
i used to struggle a lot with this
earlier but now i i think as a manager
right
i think it's a bit about how you can
deal with this as a manager and as a
recipient
as a manager i try to make it very
comfortable for the person to say you
know what if you do not agree please let
me know
right and in case you are you are
working under somebody who is
not open to it right it's going to be a
little difficult but i think you know
when
when the moment when it's not uh when
when it's when i was when the guard is
down but when the
when it's not as tense anymore right you
could always reach out
maybe it could be after the after
feedback when you go back and tell
the person to manager hey i was thinking
about the feedback you gave
but i think there might have been some
things i i you know
some things which are different i wanted
to discuss with you right so now what
you're doing is you're acknowledging
that feedback right you're not
dismissing it right you're acknowledging
and you said you're thinking about it
you thought about it and now you go back
the chances of them being receptive
increases
right and and again this is again
practically we have done it and
i have seen it work okay um
deepak asks how do you handle work
distribution bias
and how do you effectively show your
achievements from time to time to make
sure that
your supervisor knows what you're
capable of and what you're
what you'd like to do so what do you
mean by work distribution bias i
can't really repeat the question
defact asks how do you handle work
distribution bias
you know where someone else is getting
all the good
assignments and how do you effectively
show your own work
achievements to your your supervisor
from time to time
you know absolutely right i think you
know uh this is one of those things
where a small percentage of times
maybe there is a bit of favoritism right
and again i'm saying it's a very small
percentage of times because
rest of the times whoever is getting
that good piece of work
would have built their credibility in
some way
right uh so for you i think the best
thing is to see how you could build that
credibility
start with something small right show
that initiative show that you can solve
a problem for your manager right and at
the end of the day that's what we are
here to do right we are here to solve
certain problems
and you show that you can do it reliably
the more you do it
it's a it's a self-filling feedback now
if even if after doing all these if it's
not getting done you're probably in a
bit of a toxic
culture right then you sort of deal with
this accordingly but
a lot of times uh the former the thing
that i said would work
um there's another question from defuck
which is
how do you motivate juniors and
subordinates to be self-driven
yeah oh yeah i mean i think uh some of
the things that uh i said just now
right is actually coming from uh like
from my rece some some of my recent
conversations with you join us right
again uh at the end of the day everyone
is motivated uh
by different things right but what i
could imagine when i was a fresh as a
fresher
as a new joiner you're probably really
really you're really you're
very high on energy right you really
want to kind of
do something and you know just get into
the corporate world
uh strongly right and a lot of times i
think the struggle is around okay i
won't do this but i'm not either i'm not
getting the right opportunity
or i got the opportunity but i don't
know how to go about it right so i think
from my standpoint it's really about
talking about hey what is it in the
short term what is in the long
you know what is the career of objective
and how you would go there
and more importantly just kind of you
know getting that started right
it's about hey do this you know
how you do this what what i'm expecting
from you had a close connect
right and usually this level of
engagement really kind of helps right
once you start having this close connect
once you start uh acknowledging those
little uh victories and then you start
challenging them more and more and more
you really get into a place where i
think motivation is a bit intrinsic once
once you are in that in that place and
again as i said this is something
i'm drawing off from some of my recent
conversations
i'm going to ask um a question that's
come in from
uh two directions one is somebody with
experience
one is somebody who's breaking into the
field um
and they both have the the challenge
of knowing what skills to acquire
and how to do that and
so in general i think the question is
when somebody is looking to develop a
career path
or a deeper understanding of a
particular technology like ai
or they want to become a better software
developer
what would um your advice
be for how they should pursue getting
you know developing those skills
acquiring those skills
and planning out that improvement path
yeah um
i think there are two things really here
right one is about acquiring specific
skills right
and and again you know a lot of it
depends on what is your current skill
level and you know uh you look at
what is the area of interest and so on
right so and and i think that's a bit
more defined right
for me i think what is more uh more
powerful i think
is about you know whether you whether
you are
as a as an engineer are are you kind of
you know
are you curious right are you are you in
the habit of learning new things right
are you adaptable are you fungible right
and and i think the more you are that
then uh the specific technologies begin
to matter lesser and lesser right
obviously at some point you know you you
have to change the field you have to
learn
those things and yes you need to put
some effort on it
but as a habit if you if you're more
about if if you're not like i've seen
engineers you know
with with less than six months
experience right and they probably took
a training in java and you know they are
saying okay
uh i am trained in java so i want to
work in java project right uh six
and and and and that that's very uh
that's a very narrow way you're thinking
about
right so uh i think the more uh you you
expose yourself the
the learnability is a critical aspect
and some of the things i i talked about
the habit of solving problems right
those are the critical aspects if you
acquire
those right i think you know any
transition that you have
becomes a lot easier right then you
could then you could actually choose
okay i'm passionate about this right
and hence uh with all these skills you
try and learn that
and it it it it's a lot easy to acquire
once you are in that frame of mind right
and again you know it's not about
learning it's not like
learning in school where you learn some
textbook but it's really about
as engineers it's about we have to learn
the
applicability of it right if you learn
something and if you're not able to
apply
uh it's not going to be much useful it's
maybe useful to the extent that you
clear an interview but
but in your day-to-day uh practice that
won't be helpful right so
that's just some of a lot of things that
i spoke about earlier is very very
generic regardless of
which technology you you choose right
and i from my
perspective i think that would be the
foundation and on top of it you could
just choose whatever is best
in your uh best that suits you okay
um so we've reached the end of our time
um
and what i'd like to do quickly is to
ask the audience one more
poll and
we will do that
and allow me to share that with you
again if you're streaming you can
put your uh responses into the comment
but right now um what skills
are you in the audience most interested
in learning
you have a engineering heavy audience so
you're looking to develop more in
engineering fields or in fields related
around that that will move you into
management or marketing and those types
of things
and also when would you like to start
it's always
the old question when would today be the
best time to start
and i will share the results
it's a fairly rounded uh distribution of
interests
with data science and ai
and oops sorry
project management
so with that
i will
thank red vendors for this presentation
um
if you wanted to uh address those last
couple of points that you had mentioned
um to the audience please go ahead right
now
revendra and uh
floor is yours to say goodbye
thank you everyone thanks for uh you
know uh thanks for listening
um i hope that was useful okay
and um his linkedin information is on
the screen so
um please reach out if you'd like to
connect with him
i do want to thank uh
freshersworld for being sponsored for
today's session
and pressure's world um
is a as the name implies is a
job portal for people starting out in
their careers
um part of the team least set of
companies
uh they have other services for people
who are farther along
in their careers and
like to mention one other program that
we have at simply learn which is skill
up
something we started within the last
year
this is free access to our on-demand
video content
these are not our full
certification courses but these are
self-study and allow you to get started
in different fields see
what things might
ignite your passion and
gives you a good way to get a feel for
this content you do receive
a completion certificate at the end of
these courses
and again this is all free i've dropped
the
link into the chat a couple of times
i'll do that one more time
and
the last thing before we completely end
the webinar
is to mention that we do have another
webinar coming up
next week on wednesday this is in the
digital marketing space
um if that's something of interest to
you
this is a master class in
managing match type changes for
pay-per-click marketing
kind of a narrow definition but if some
of you are
engineers involved with digital
marketing
this might be something you're
interested in if not
let your friends who are working in that
field know
and with that we're going to end the
webinar um
we would like love to have you reach out
to us
on our social media platforms on
facebook twitter
and linkedin pretty much you can find us
under the name simply learn
and again
thank you to rugbendra thank you to all
of you for being here today with
us and um we hope that you found this
webinar enjoyable and useful and
we will be sending you out a uh a link
to the recording so that you'll be
able to review what revenge shared with
us today
thanks
you